and it's a beautiful day as
denny matthews put it we've had warmer
opening days but we've had a lot more
colder opening days than today we'll
take sunshine
ground ball past third and isaiah is on
to start the season
trying to stretch it for two and the
throws cut off it's a double
for isaiah and a great start for the
rangers in 2021.
with the payoff pitch that one belted
out to right field
and off the top of the fence that'll get
the first run of the season to the plate
or no it will not connor falefa
slammed on the breaks at third and he
must not have gotten
any kind of read at all off the bat no i
don't know if he got duped or
not by isabel who is out in right field
this looked like might have been a
little cutter 14 fastball didn't do much
stayed up
in the top of the zone let's take a look
at isaiah he goes back to tag
and i just wonder at some point if he
thought there was an opportunity
for that ball to be caught and that's
why he had tagged up
and the texas rangers have the bases
loaded with nobody out in the top of the
first inning
first base is loaded at bat of the year
and it's for nick zolac
3-1 pitch and a slow tapper could be
trouble
keller maybe a little slip can't get it
to first in time
still nobody out the rangers finally get
that first run across
it's one nothing low another
newcomer to this rangers team this is
his
first opening day roster acquired by the
rangers part of a six-player trade
this offseason in the air left field
headed toward the line drops in that's a
base hit and more
ben and tendy couldn't quite get it two
runs are in
they'll wave solac and no throw offered
a bases clearing double for nate lowe
and the rangers jump out for nothing
i don't think you could draw it up any
better how would you want your first
inning to go
to start off a season three doubles a
single walk and four runs on the board
and this one
ripped right side that one caroms off of
merrifield everybody's safe as low gets
to third
and the beat goes on in this first
inning
this one lined to the gap drops in base
hit
low scores and it's five nothing rangers
seven up seven on
for the rangers runners at first and
second and nobody out
he'll hit it to left field and that is
up along the
side wall and bentendi makes a terrific
play
and gets it to third with no further
advance
and royals fans finally have something
to cheer about
and i'll tell you what it sure is
looking good with the fans in the stands
this is beautiful
it looks a lot more like there's more
fans than ten thousand but
i tell you they all gave ben and tindy a
nice round of applause
there as this was not easy this is mrs
first time
in a first catch like this in this
ballpark for him that was beautiful
way to help him out start to his batting
stance
bloop to center field taylor's coming up
he's going to play it on a bounce
holt is coming to the plate and the
throw is going to be
in time
and the defense the outfield defense the
brand new
outfield defense has come up big for
keller in this inning and
who would have expected it keller's a
ground ball pitcher and everything has
been in the air
but hey the outfielders are helping him
out now this ta this ball
was well thrown but it's on the first
base side of the plate
and so salvador perez has to reach way
over and make that tag you can see how
he shifted his feet
and laid that glove right there on hold
and i'll tell you
keller is getting picked up now in a big
way
has some defense there for you and the
royals know how to do that that's a
staple for them
have the bases loaded with nobody out in
the first inning wow
and here comes salvi defense outside for
a walk
so salvi comes back after being down in
the count
and the first four reach for the royals
and it's 5-1 and solaire
takes a walk and the royals have
three in a row after merrifield and
benintendi
single to open the game and he gets a
line driving to right and it's down for
a hit
that'll get a run home it is 5-3
and kyle isbill down in the count one
ball
two strikes gets his first major league
hit
and his first major league rbi
kansas city is going to love this guy
michael
a taylor's first hat bat is it royal and
that's into center field
salvi scores it is 5-4
with one out in the bottom of the first
you
never know what you're gonna see when
you come to a big league baseball game
keep the line moving
and lopez hits it well to center field
that's going to tie the game
as tavares looks up into the sun
solaire comes down from third and the
royals
answer the rangers with five at least
in the bottom of the first inning
nikki lopez coming through there that's
a
huge at-bat for him one away
a two-minute scoring position for nate
lowe
nate lowe he had a bases clearing double
and he shoots this one out to left field
that'll get one run home and the rangers
have retaken the lead
opposite field rbi single for low he has
four rbis he had a slow spring
seventh pitch of the at-bat on the way
and up the middle base hit
trevino's in here comes connor falefa
he'll score all the way to third base
david dahl
[Music]
and so gallo brings home a pair and the
rangers now lead eight to five
in the air left center field tester
dahl tags taylor's already thrown out a
runner at the plate
here's another good throw and another
outfield assist for michael a taylor
wow this is a perfect throw
stayed behind it didn't take any time
getting rid of it
that was awesome in addition to two
outfield assists taylor has an rbi
single
and there's a drive to right field with
no wind
so it will carry and it is gone
we're not even three innings into this
game and michael a taylor
is officially a kansas city royal
whoa what a statement swing that was
my goodness he's got two outfield
assists already
and now he's goes oppo papo
with his first royal home run we knew he
had power
but man santana hits it hard into left
field
lopez will be waived home it's a one-run
game
carlos santana has had a heck of a day
he has two walks
a run scored and now his first rbi is a
royal and you could
that ball is crushed how far will it go
jorge soler has tied the game at eight
in the fourth inning how many
solar flex packs do you want
just flex them up and get it in the air
solar
that was beautiful wow
and he has another base hit here comes
dozier around
third and the royals for the first time
today
have the lead and michael a taylor has
driven in three fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]
in the air to right field gallows
looking up into the sun he gets some
forward momentum
here comes isbell the throw is up the
line everybody advances and the royals
lead by two
to white and that one up the middle base
hit
real smothered by the second baseman
who's sort of the plate is late
mayorfield i i'm a little shocked that
he got to it
his belt grounds it out towards short
and kiner falefa
realizing there was no double play
thought about home and that cost him an
out
especially how about this oh my
whit merrifield hits the royals
third home run today that's his third
hit
and that's how he greets lefty colby
allard and the royals have scored
14 today
[Applause]
and davis gets the strikeout
and the save in his royals return
waiter check please